sie demonstrieren für einen freien iran
anhänger der iranischen auslands
opposition paris 2018
was viele nicht wissen sie entgehen nur
knapp einem attentat
der anschlag wird vereitelt europaweit
sind geheimdienste den drahtziehern auf
den fersen deutschen ermittlern geht
assadullah die ins netz er soll getarnt
als diplomat an einer iranischen
botschaft den anschlag geplant und ein
agenten netzwerk aufgebaut haben im
februar wieder zu 20 jahren haft
verurteilt seitdem sitzt er in belgrad
wird iran versuchen assadullah die
freizupressen
auch gegen deutsche geiseln in
iranischen gefängnissen
wir treffen mariam klaren in köln ihre
mutter gehört zu den deutschen
staatsbürgern den iran festgehalten
werden navi hat sich politisch nie
öffentlich geäußert arbeitete als
architektin in deutschland im oktober
2020 wird sie in ihrer wohnung in
teheran verhaftet anklagepunkte sind
nicht bekannt sie sei ein
sicherheitsrisiko heißt es monatelang
sitzt die 66 jährige mit deutschen und
iranischen pass in isolationshaft
sie hat kein tageslicht bekommen wenn
sie 20 minuten am tag an die frische
luft geführt worden ist wusste sie eine
augenbinde tragen es seien die hohen
gefängnismauern
ihre haare sind ausgefallen ihre haut
fühlt sich angeschlagen papier sieht
kein obst und gemüse bekommen
sie hat es selber genannt im o-ton mein
körper ist total kaputt und wenn sie
mich fragen ist das der inbegriff von
folter ausländer und doppelstaatler als
geiseln zu nutzen hat system im
gottesstaat
es ist mittlerweile eine geübte
iranische praxis geiseln zu nehmen
und zwar werden dann westliche
staatsbürger in iran unter meist
vollkommen an den haaren herbeigezogenen
vorwürfen verhaftet und die werden
anschließend als tauschgeschäft
angeboten und in der regel geht es darum
iraner oder auch von den iranischen
diensten beauftragt nicht iraner in
europa oder anderswo in der westlichen
welt freizupressen
irgendwo im großraum los angeles hier
leben über eine million iraner das der
iran auch vor entführungen nicht
zurückschreckt hat die familie schauen
macht erfahren
sie haben lange in deutschland gelebt im
september wird der vater von casale und
charme
ein deutsch iranischer staatsbürger in
dubai gekidnappt und nach teheran
entführt die kinder unter schock
auf einmal rufen uns freuen dann sagen
hier guck mal auf youtube dein papa ist
auf youtube
was ist los erst dann sieht man ihn dort
mit einer augenbinde schrecklich im
staatsfernsehen gesteht gary shaw nacht
beobachter sprechen von einem zwangs
geständnis soll der oppositionsgruppe
torn daran gehören und wird von teheran
für einen anschlag auf eine moschee in
chinas verantwortlich gemacht ihm droht
die todesstrafe
die familie hat große angst und ich kann
mut machen und keiner ist da und selbst
dann kein jux auch mariam klaren kämpft
von köln aus täglich um die freilassung
ihrer mutter mit wenig erfolg
ich habe direkt vom ersten tag an mich
an die deutschen behörden gewandt und um
konsularische betreuung meiner mutter
gebeten vor allen dingen um auflösung
und freilassung meiner mutter aber ich
habe noch nie positives feedback von den
deutschen behörden vom auswärtigen amt
bekommen wir fragen nach beim
auswärtigen amt schriftlich teilt man
uns mit
die bundesregierung hat sich mehrfach
auch hochrangig für die betroffenen
eingesetzt
der iran gewährt jedoch in aller regel
keinen konsularischen zugang zu
häftlingen die auch die iranische
staatsangehörigkeit besitzen iran
erkennt bei doppelstaatler nur die
iranische staatsangehörigkeit an
menschenrechtsorganisationen fordern
humanitäre haftbedingungen und wir
fordern konkret das rechtsstaatliche
verfahren im iran durchgeführt werden
dass zb die angeklagten anwalt ihrer
wahrnehmen können dass geständnisse die
unter folter abgelegt werden nicht
akzeptiert werden vor gericht das ist
bisher nämlich der fall mehr als zwei
dutzend ausländer und doppelstaatler
sitzen in iranischen gefängnissen als
faustpfand als geiseln er ist im
november hat er an eine australische
wissenschaftlerin für drei in thailand
festgehaltene iraner freigelassen
doch der verurteilte agent asadi im
austausch für geiseln im iran freikommen
ich gehe fest davon aus dass es schon
verhandlungen über einen möglichen
austausch gibt allerdings sollten sich
die europäischen regierungen sehr genau
überlegen inwieweit sie diese praxis
auch in zukunft fortsetzen sie haben
sich zumindest in einigen fällen als
erpressbar erwiesen das ist kein
dauerzustand wenn wir politik mit der
islamischen republik betreiben wollen
für die schau macht in kalifornien wäre
ein austausch die chance ihren kranken
vater noch lebend wiederzusehen mariam
in köln macht es wütend dass ihre mutter
eine geisel teherans ist es kotzt mich
an dass meine 66 jährige mutter
spielball und verhandlungsmasse für
irgendwelche beziehungen und frei
erpressungsversuchen oder bessere
ausgangsposition schaffen für den iran
ist ich werde keine ruhe geben bis sie
wieder neben mir steht bei der festnahme
von doppelstaatler wie marians mutter
geht es ihr darum inhaftierte agenten im
ausland freizupressen aber auch immer um
eine botschaft ins innere regime
kritiker einzuschüchtern